- YOU--LET ME THROUGH.
THIS IS BULLSHIT, GENE.
- WHOA, WHOA, WHOA, WAIT.
WHAT'S THE MATTER, RICH?
- IN THE NEXT EPISODE
STEVE URKEL TURNS CARL
INTO A GIANT SANDWICH
AND ACCIDENTALLY EATS HIM?
- HA-HA, BUT WAIT,
THAT'S HILARIOUS, BUDDY.
IT'S HILARIOUS.
- COME ON!
I'M AN ACTOR, GENE!
THIS WAS SUPPOSED
TO BE ABOUT ME AND MY FAMILY.
- I KNOW,
BUT YOU KNOW, AFTER THAT--
AFTER THAT FIRST GUEST SPOT
WITH STEVE URKEL,
I MEAN, AMERICA FELL IN LOVE
WITH HIM, MAN.
WE HAD TO MAKE HIM A REGULAR,
AND NOW, YOU KNOW--
HEY, LISTEN, HE'S THE STAR
OF THE SHOW NOW, SWEETHEART.
WE GOTTA PLAY BALL, BUBBELEH.
- DON'T YOU DARE
"BUBBELEH" ME, GENE.
NOW, LAST WEEK, STEVE USED
HIS TRANSFORMATION MACHINE
TO TURN CARL INTO A CAR
AND DRIVE HIM AROUND
THE MONACO GRAND PRIX?
COME ON!
HOW MANY TIMES YOU GONNA
USE THIS TRANSFORMATION MACHINE?
THIS WAS SUPPOSED
TO BE A BLUE COLLARCOSBY SHOW.
NOW YOU'RE TURNING IT
INTO GODDAMNQUANTUM LEAP.
WHO WRITES THIS SHIT?
- OKAY, I COULDN'T TELL YOU
EVEN IF I WANTED TO, OKAY, MAN?
WE GOT, LIKE,
21 WRITERS UP THERE, OKAY?
KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING,
REGINALD?
BUT YOU AND I BOTH KNOW
THAT THEY DON'T DECIDE
WHAT HAPPENS IN THIS SHOW, OKAY?
WE BOTH KNOW WHO DECIDES
WHAT HAPPENS IN THE SHOW.
- TWO WEEKS AGO STEVE URKEL USED
HIS INVISIBILITY RAY ON CARL
AND I WASN'T
EVEN IN THE GODDAMN EPISODE.
IT WAS JUST MY VOICE.
- YES, I KNOW.
I KNOW, REGINALD.
I'M SORRY.
I FUCKING APOLOGIZE.
IT'LL NEVER HAPPEN AGAIN.
- THEN STEVE USED HIS
VOICE-CHANGING RAY TO TURN CARL
INTO A HIGH-PITCHED,
NERDY VOICE.
WHO DO YOU THINK
PROVIDED THE VOICE FOR THAT?
- DON'T GET TOO FEISTY
ON ME NOW, REG.
LET'S NOT GO DOWN THAT PATH,
OKAY?
- OH, OH, WE ARE GOING
DOWN THAT PATH, GENE.
IN A COUPLE OF WEEKS,
HARRIET, EDDIE, LAURA, GRANDMA,
AUNT RACHEL, LITTLE RICHIE,
AND THE OTHER LITTLE KID
ARE GONNA GET TELEPORTED
TO ANOTHER DIMENSION,
AND THEN STEVE INJECTS CARL
WITH HIS OWN DNA,
SO CARL
TURNS INTO ANOTHER STEVE URKEL.
THAT'S TWO STEVE URKELS
AND NO FAMILY
ON A SHOW CALLEDFAMILY MATTERS.
HOW THE FUCK DOES THAT WORK?
- LISTEN, LISTEN, REGINALD.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO TELL YOU.
URKEL MANIA IS UNSTOPPABLE,
OKAY?
HE'S A PHENOMENON.
THERE'S NOTHING
WE CAN DO ABOUT IT, OKAY?
IT'S UP TO S--
HIM.
- NO, NO, NO, NO, NO!
I'M AN ACTOR.
I'M A FUCKING ACTOR.
I AM A REAL ACTOR.
I DIDRICHARD III.
I WAS INTRUE WEST■
WITH SHERMAN HEMSLEY.
I WAS INDIEHARD,DAMN IT.
FUCK STEVE URKEL!
- FUCK--
YOU WILL SUCK
STEVE URKEL'S FUCK
IF HE WANTS YOU TO!
YOU WILL SUCK HIS FUCKING DICK,
DO YOU UNDERSTAND?
HE IS OUR BREAD AND BUTTER,
YOU MOTHERFUCKER!
I AM HIGH ON COCAINE!
- I'M A FUCKING ACTOR, GENE!
I DONE MORE COCAINE
THAN YOU WEIGH, MOTHERFUCKER!
- I'M GONNA TELL YOU WHAT YOU
ARE, REGINALD VELJOHNSON.
YOU'RE A FUCKING PAWN
IN THAT NERD'S GAME.
YOU ARE A FUCKING PAWN!
DO YOU THINK I HAVE ANY POWER
OVER WHAT THAT MONSTER DOES?
ANY POWER AT ALL?
- AHH!
- I AM THE SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT
OF DEVELOPMENT
FOR THE AMERICAN BRO--
- GENE?
GENE?
GENE, WHAT'S BECOME OF YOU,
- I AM NOTHING.
- GENE, I DON'T KNOW
WHAT YOU MEAN BY THAT, GENE,
BUT YOU'RE SCARING ME.
OH, NO, DON'T, DON'T,
DON'T DO ANYTHING CRAZY, GENE.
EVERYONE DOES TOO MUCH COKE
SOMETIMES,
BUT DO THE--JUST, WHAT ARE YOU
GONNA DO WITH THE GUN, GENE?
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
DON'T--NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO.
WE CAN TALK THIS THROUGH.
OKAY?
- THE KING IS DEAD.
LONG LIVE THE KING.
- NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO!
- DID I DO THAT?
- JALEEL.
- JALEEL?
THERE IS NO JALEEL.
ONLY STEVE.
IT'S ALWAYS BEEN STEVE.
- YIPPIE KI-YAY, MOTHERFUCKER!
[gun clicking]
- FORGETTING SOMETHING, CARL?
- DON'T YOU COME NEAR ME.
STAY AWAY FROM ME, YOU HEAR?
- COULD HAVE ALL BEEN SO SIMPLE,
CARL.
JUST SAY YOUR LINES
AND TAKE THE MONEY.
- YOU'RE A MONSTER.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
I, I, I, I CAN'T CONTROL--
- AM I DOING THIS?
- NO, NO, NO,
NO, NO, NO, NO, NO.
STEVE, I'LL DO ANYTHING.
- YOU WILL DO
WHAT I WANT ONFAMILY MATTERS.
- YES, YES.
OF COURSE, STEVE.
- SEE YOU ON SET, CARL.
- GET OUT OF MY HOUSE, STEVE!